[Music]
we're running out of time you've seen
what's happening out there
[Music]
[Music]
I can handle Thomas I can show up
eventually that's what I'm afraid of
they took you because you're immune to a
plague that's wiping out the human race
they think you're worth sacrificing to
find a cure them every stop stop that
the last city breaks the whole base of
operations mr. meyen standard model
Ashford was on three years we spent
behind walls just trying to break out
now it's gonna break back in all right I
guess shotgun
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it to regret
are you just hosting I did what I
thought was right there's no guarantee
we make your back feet don't we stop
this together as well I'll end it that
way too
[Music]
you still care about it down here cool
item 8 come on
annotates believe the roundup torture
kill when how does it sound
it stops we'll find a cure
[Music]
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
please hey pay attention this is yours
[Music]
most important thing keep your finger
off the trigger at all times unless you
need to shoot somebody when that happens
until you run dry
keep your eyes open every cop in the
country is gonna be looking for us
big Nick original gangster cop in the
flesh
watch italic four dead six on the way to
the hospital I think he's a bad guy I'm
gonna make you a deal
give me the names of all guys who got
away I'll get dramatic ain't no snitch
yo he's dying son we got a problem it's
a major crime get to know your enemy
boys every big-time crew has been busted
these are the guys who took them down by
magician
sooner or later he'll need your fix you
could yeah we're doing Santa plans
we're trading up the Federal Reserve
it's like Fort Knox
at any one time there's anywhere between
500 and 800 billion dollars in there
every millimeter are covered by cameras
sensors and motion detectors 10 brush
stream stare at building for two minutes
now security on your ass and the bag has
never been robbed
[Music]
you know just means means I am a member
of a gang well we have badges which
means you are done you look like the
type from the rest you know our cadets
ego put you in handcuffs drag you down
the description
we just shoot you
you're not the bad guys
we are like the whole city girl I kiss
me take off your dress
when I was in Moscow I heard about a
program
young officers drink to seduce and
manipulate these our bodies
use everything color sparrows that's
what she is
[Music]
do you ever feel weird weird sometimes I
feel like I'm always on the outside
there's this invisible line that I have
to cross to really be a part of
everything and I just can't ever cross
it me too
my name's Simon I'm just like you except
I have one huge ass secret boots I said
I like your boots
goodbye nobody knows I'm gay sometimes I
feel like I'm stuck on a ferris wheel
one minute I'm on top of the world
[Music]
in the next cement rock-bottom
I've been thinking about why I haven't
come out yet maybe part of me wants to
hold on to who I've always been
just a little longer
[Music]
[Music]
no matter what announcing who you are to
the world is pretty terrifying because
what if the world doesn't like you
[Music]
PS doesn't seem fair that only gay
people have to come out why is straight
to default I have something I need to
tell you I like girls trying to get me
I like men I'm straight
[Music]
good morning wife
[Music]
this is great look out your window why
I'm taking you away for the weekend I
just can't believe this is my life that
I get to live with you
buzzes huh
that meant nothing to me before you can
a great office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor I bought it for us I
should have asked you first
oh my god
Christian this is Jim Matteo the
architect this location is perfect I'm
going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking in my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
grey I'll pick you up at 5:00 I may not
be done by then
program follows
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
so you want to play yes sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her
to comfort few 1 times in need and to
keep you safe first long as we both
shall live
[Music]
how would you define terrorism
[Music]
the current definition is any individual
or group and uses violence to achieve
political goal
the administration believes that the
drug cartels
fit that definition
[Music]
you want to see this thing through I'm
gonna have to get dirty turning you
loose all those new rules this time
[Music]
[Music]
you know help us start a war with hope
[Music]
everyone I have seen gods fly I've seen
men build weapons that I couldn't even
imagine I've seen aliens drop from the
sky yeah but I have never seen anything
like this
how much boy you hiding
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of King you
are going to be don't please
[Music]
[Music]
damn
because we own
because we all know
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people who need help with matters that
can't be explained come to me these
hauntings can be terrifying things I
should know I've faced many evils in my
life this was different though the
haunted house it's my family's house if
we can find out what it is we can stop
this curse to end this evil I need to go
deeper into the further
I don't have memories from this place I
have scars I'm gonna find it and I'm
gonna finish it
at least there's someone right in front
of you I don't see anything be careful
you going to touch
[Music]